The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high-quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
GEORGE VERGHESE: The course is
called Digital Communication
Systems.
So I wanted to say a bit
about what that means.
And the easiest way to do that
is to contrast it with analog.
What's analog communication?
Well, in analog
communication, you're
typically focused
on communicating
some kind of a waveform.
So you've got some continuous
waveform, typically, an x of t,
maybe the voltage picked up
at a microphone at the source,
and you want to get it
across to a receiver.
And it's under this
umbrella that you
have things like
amplitude modulation,
frequency modulation, and so on.
These are all schemes
aimed at transmitting
a continuous waveform
of this type.
So an amplitude modulation,
for instance, what you'll do
is you'll take a
sinusoidal carrier.
The carrier carries
the information
about the analog waveform,
and basically, it's
a high-frequency sinusoid
whose amplitude is varied
in proportion to the signal.
I haven't drawn it too well.
It's supposed to be
constant frequency and just
the amplitude varying.
So this is something
of the type x of t
cosine 2 pi fc t, for instance.
It's a sinusoid
of a fixed carrier
frequency with the
amplitude varying slowly.
In FM, what you do is you have
a fixed amplitude waveform,
but you vary the frequency.
So what you might do is have
high frequency in this part,
and then when the signal goes
low, the frequency gets lower.
And then it gets higher
where the signal is high.
So there's a modulation
of the frequency,
but the amplitude stays fixed.
The good thing about this
is you can be transmitting
at full power all the
time, and the information
is coded onto
frequency, whereas this
can tend to be more
susceptible to noise.
But the focus is on an analog
waveform and transmitting that.
Now, in digital communication
the focus changes.
So in digital, we think in
terms of sources with messages.
So we have messages.
There's a source
of some kind that
puts out a stream of symbols.
So at Time 1, there's
some symbol emitted.
At Time 2, there's some
other symbol, symbol, symbol.
And these are all
heading to the receiver.
So already we're thinking
of a clocked kind of system.
We're thinking of
symbols being transmitted
at a particular rate.
We're thinking of these
discrete objects rather than
continuous waveforms.
And the focus is then
on getting a message
across as opposed to
getting a waveform across
with high fidelity.
And that turns out to actually
be a big shift in perspective.
These symbols, then, will
often get coded onto--
for instance, the symbols,
if they originally were,
let's say an A, B,
C, D, for instance--
coding the grades in a class--
you might want to, when
you're transmitting them,
to adopt those symbols to what
your channel is able to take.
And maybe your
channel is one that's
able to distinguish
between two states,
but maybe not between
four states, so you
might want to code these
onto a channel that--
well, onto strings
of 0's and 1's,
so that you can impress
this on a channel that
can respond to just two states.
So you might have a coding
step that takes the original
symbols, puts out a
stream of 0's and 1's.
And then you've got the task
of decoding the message.
The channel might
corrupt these streams,
and that's another thing
that you have to deal with.
So what's made digital explode
is the fact that it's really
well matched to computation,
memory, storage,
all the stuff that's
advancing rapidly.
In the world of
analog, you're talking
about analog electronics,
which is also advancing greatly
but doesn't have the
same flexibility.
Here, you can do
all sorts of things
with digital and with the
computation that's available,
and that's growing
in power all the time
to do more and
more fancy things.
So digital
communication is really
most of what you see around you.
So when you talk on the phone,
or do computer-to-computer
communication, or
browse the web,
and so on, it's really
digital communication that
you're talking about--
with one little caveat, I guess.
When you get down to the
details of how you get a 0 and 1
across on a channel, you're back
in the analog physical world.
And you tend to be
doing things that
are much closer to what you
worry about on analog channels.
And we'll see that
in this course.
So for most of
what we talk about,
we'll be working at the level
of the digital abstraction here.
But when we come to talking
about transmission on a link,
and modulation, and
demodulation, and the like,
we're back in the analog world.
And you'll actually
get a good feel
for some of this in the course
of our digital communication.
So to give you a sense of
how the course is structured,
we'll spend some time,
first of all, talking
about information--
information in a message
and how you measure
it, how you code it up.
So this is sort of the
bits piece of the course.
And then we'll talk about
how to get these messages
across single channels.
So this is a single link
source at one end, receiver
at the other end.
And we'll focus on how
you get the data across.
And that brings us
to the analog world
and to the world of signals,
so we'll spend time on that.
And that's sort of the
second third of the course.
And then the last
third of the course,
which Harry will
actually be lecturing,
focuses on now when you have
interconnected networks.
So you've got
multiple links, so you
might want to communicate
from some source
here to a receiver that's
way across on the network,
going through multiple
links and multiple nodes.
And there are all
sorts of issues there.
And there, we're thinking
in terms of a packet
kind of abstraction.
It's packets that we
ship around the network
with associated
logic, and mechanisms
for failure detection
in the network,
and coping with all
of that So there
are these three sort of
chunks to the course,
and you'll see that
in the notes as well.
So we'll start off
with the bits piece.
That's more or less Quiz one.
Then we'll get to
the signals piece.
That's more or less
Quiz two, and we'll
get to the packets piece, and
that's more or less Quiz three.
And these will be
relatively modular.
So you get a chance to make a
fresh start on each of them.
But you'll find us reaching
back to build on ideas developed
earlier in the course.
Now, as I think about
where digital communication
originated, it
actually turns out
to be largely due to the person
who painted this painting.
This is called "The
Gallery of the Louvre."
This is somebody who
painted it in around 1830,
an American painter.
He was actually
born in Charleston,
close to here, studied
at Yale, made enough
of a name for himself that
he had commissions to paint
portraits and the like.
He was actually called
to Washington, DC
to paint a portrait of the
markets, the Lafayette.
While he was there, he got
a telegram from his father
saying that his wife in
New Haven was convalescing.
By the time he got
to New Haven, which
was as soon as he could-- he
abandoned the painting he was
doing and left for New Haven--
by the time he got there,
he found that she had
actually died and been buried.
And that sort of
fortified him for what
he decided was his
life's work, which
was to find better
ways to communicate,
faster ways to communicate.
He didn't want to have
to depend on horse riders
to carry messages or
ships across the ocean.
He's actually painted
himself into the middle
of that painting.
These were some friends
that he made in Paris.
It's actually the author,
James Fenimore Cooper,
of The Last of
the Mohicans fame.
He was actually hoping
to sell his painting
to Fenimore Cooper, but things
didn't work out that way.
In any case, this
is a huge painting.
It's about six
feet by nine feet.
He wrapped it up to bring
it back to the States.
It wasn't quite finished.
This was about 1831 or so.
And on the boat,
he met this person
who had a little electromagnet
that he was playing with.
And they had
various discussions,
and he got the idea
for a telegraph.
Anyone with a guess
as to the name?
Morse.
Now we think of Morse
as the Morse code guy,
but it turns out
that he actually
did hugely more than the code.
So that's Samuel Morse,
looks pretty imposing.
He didn't just come
up with the code,
he actually invented
the whole system.
Now, he didn't work in a vacuum.
There were people doing related
things in different places,
but his was the first practical
essentially single-wire system.
If you look at his
patent documents,
he's got all the
little pieces that it
takes to make the system.
A key piece was
actually the relay.
So he figured out,
working with a colleague
back in New York, he figured
out that with a little battery,
you could close an
electromagnet or you
could power an electromagnet
at some distance.
But you couldn't have
that wire be too long.
So what he arranged was a relay
where that electromagnet then
pulls another piece of
metal, which then closes
another switch on
a separate circuit,
so you can then start to
propagate the signal over very
large distances.
And that was really a key
part of his invention.
Morse code-- there's
actually some discussion
as to whether he invented
it or it was actually
his assistant Vail, but it's
called "Morse code" anyway.
The other staggering
thing about this story
is how soon after
the invention--
I mean, his patent
was, let's see,
1840, very early in the
days of the Patent Office,
as you can see from the
numbers assigned to the patent.
About 15 years later, there
were people raising money
to lay cable across the
Atlantic to carry telegrams.
So can you imagine, partly
the bravery of these people?
I mean, it's hard enough
to think of laying cable
across Boston Harbor.
And they were prepared to design
this cable, load it on a ship,
and lay it across
the entire Atlantic.
They made an attempt in 1857.
It actually turned out to
work for about three weeks.
That was long enough
for Queen Victoria
to congratulate
President Buchanan,
except it took
almost all of a day
to get the 98 words across
from one side to the other.
And the reason is when
you put a little pulse
on one end of a
very long cable, it
distorts like mad by the time
it gets to the other end.
So you can barely detect--
if you put a sharp
change in one end
and you've got a long
cable, and if it's
a poorly designed cable,
it takes a long time
to detect the rise at the other
end if you detect it at all.
It turns out the person
at the American end
was the person who would
later become Lord Kelvin.
He was called plain old
Walter Thomson at that point.
He had designed a
very sensitive way
to measure these changes in
voltage at the ends of cables.
But the person at
the British end
was actually a surgeon,
a self-taught electrical
engineer, who was convinced that
the problem was there was not
enough voltage on the cable.
So he kept cranking
up the voltage.
When he got to 2,000
volts, the cable failed.
And so there had been
celebrations in the street,
and there had been
fireworks, and all of that.
And then people got
very angry, and thought
this was a scam, and a way to
raise money, and all of that.
Despite all of the
negative press,
a year later here
was this man again,
with enough funding from
governments and private sources
to make another
attempt at the cable.
Anyway, it took a while.
It took a good nine years
to finally lay a good cable.
They'd gone out about 1,200
miles with a cable in 1865
before it broke.
They had to start again in 1866.
They managed to lay
an entire cable,
and then they came
back and found
the broken end of
the 1865 cable,
and picked it up,
and continued it.
So in 1866, they managed
to get two cables working.
And now it was a lot faster--
eight words a minute.
It was digital communication.
It's got all the
ingredients of what we see
in digital communication today.
And then a little
while later, there
was a transcontinental
line, which
marked the end of, essentially,
the Pony Express trying
to carry mail across
the continent.
Now much more was going to
happen on telegraph lines.
There was a transpacific
line in 1902,
so that meant at that point,
you could encircle the globe
with telegraph.
So it was really a
transformative technology.
And it was a digital
technology because all
you were trying to figure
out at the other end
was whether something
was a dot or a dash.
It was just basically
two states that you
were trying to distinguish.
That's his Patent
Office documents.
Actually, they're interesting to
read, but let's just see here--
"Be it known that I, the
undersigned, Samuel F. B.
Morse, have invented a new
and useful machine and system
of signs for
transmitting intelligence
between distant points by the
means of a new application
and effect of electromagnetism."
And then he goes on to describe
the equipment and the code
itself.
This is just a map to show
you the kind of distance
that they had to lay
that first cable over.
Morse code you've all seen.
It's gone through some
evolution, actually.
Actually, Morse
originally thought
of just a code for
numbers, and then
he imagined a dictionary
at the two ends,
and you would just
send the number
for the word in the dictionary,
and someone would look it up
at the other end.
But then with Vail, they
developed this scheme.
You notice the most
frequently used letter
has the shortest symbol here.
It's just a dot.
And then if you go to an A,
it's a dot, dash, and so on.
The T, I think, is a dash.
Yeah.
So the choice of symbols sort
of matches the expected symbol
frequencies in English text.
You want the more
frequently used letters
to have the shorter
symbols because there
are going to be many
of them, and you
don't want to be sending
along code words with them.
But this was Morse code.
Here's another way
to represent it.
So going to the left is a dot,
going to the right is a dash.
So a single dot brings
you to an E. A dot,
dot brings you to an I, dot,
dot, dot to an S. Dash dot
brings you to an N, and so on.
So you can display
this code on a graph.
One thing you see right
away from this display,
and it was clear
from the code itself,
is you're not going
to be able to get away
with just two symbols.
Because if you're trying to
get to an A on this path,
you hit an E on the way.
And you need something to tell
you that you aren't done yet.
So there is a third symbol,
and that's the space.
So Morse code has dot,
a dash, and a space.
It's really a
three-symbol alphabet,
and the space is critical.
If you want to have a code
where you can deduce instantly
that you've hit the letter
that the sender intends,
you need all the letters
to be at the ends
here, at the leaves of the tree.
If you have all the code words
at the leaves of the tree,
right at the ends,
then you're not
going to encounter any other
code words along the way.
So you just keep
going down the tree,
dot to the left,
dash to the right,
till you hit the code word at
the end, and then you're done.
But in this kind
of arrangement, you
need a third symbol,
actually, to demarcate
the different words.
So this made Morse a
very celebrated man.
He got patents in
various places.
He got medals from
all over the world,
including the Sultan of Turkey.
I believe this one
is a Diamond Medal
from the Sultan of Turkey.
He was celebrated on postage
stamps, and all deservedly so.
He really made a huge
difference to communication,
and set digital communication
on the current path.
So I've got to skip
forward very quickly
now to bring me to the
part of the story I
want to continue with.
So we're going to hopscotch
over a whole bunch of, again,
transformative inventions.
There was a telephone in '76,
again with Boston connections.
It was really thought of as
speech telegraphy at that time,
so it wasn't the telephone yet.
Bell's patent is titled
"Improvement in Telegraphy."
There was wireless
telegraphy, which
was Marconi sending signals from
Europe to, actually, Cape Cod,
but it was not voice.
It was Morse code,
basically, dots and dashes.
And then here came
analog communication.
So this was exactly what
I talked about, AM and FM,
and then later video
images, and so on.
So there's a lot of this
going on during this period.
A big player in the
theory, that company-- this
was actually Bell Labs.
The Bell Labs is
really full of people
who made a huge difference to
the development of all this.
In fact, I had some names
listed on a previous slide.
Let me see if I--
I passed over them
without mention.
But in the development
of the telegraph,
I've mentioned Lord
Kelvin already.
He did a lot to model
transmission lines
and to show how to
design better ones.
Design of magnets
and the invention
of the relay-- that
was actually Joseph
Henry, a Professor at
Colombia, after whom the unit
of inductance is named.
That's the Henry, and
various other people.
So this technology really
was a very fertile kind
of ground for people
to develop things in.
And if you take other
courses in the department,
these are names you will
encounter all over the place--
Nyquist, Bode, e But the
one I want to focus on
is Claude Shannon, who's
sort of the patron saint
of this subject, I would say.
Shannon did his Master's
degree here at MIT.
It's been called one of the
most influential Master's theses
ever, because he developed
Boolean algebra as a way
to design logic circuits.
The logic circuits
he was talking about
were relay circuits of the
time, but this was very quickly
picked up, and
quoted, and applied.
And then he moved on to
something else for his PhD.
And I don't know the extent to
which that's been influential
in genetics.
But then he joined
Bell Labs just
about the start
of the war years.
A lot of work on cryptography
during that time,
initially classified but then a
declassified version published.
During that time, he
also had interaction
with Alan Turing, who was
working on cryptography
in England, but had been
sent over to Bell Labs
to share ideas.
And then in 1948, a
groundbreaking paper
that really is the basis for
information theory today.
So it was this that developed
a mathematical basis
for digital communications.
And the impact has been
just incredible since then.
So that's what we want to
talk about a little bit.
Now I have here a
checklist that I
don't want you to look
at now, but the theory
that Shannon developed is
actually a mathematical theory.
It's a probabilistic theory.
And if you're going to be doing
calculations with probability,
you need to know some basics.
What I put down
there is a checklist.
We don't have a probability
prerequisite for this course.
We assume you've seen some in
high school, some in 601, some
elsewhere.
By the way, I should say that
all these slides are going
to be on the web, or
maybe they're on the web
already, so you don't have
to scramble to copy all this.
We'll put the lecture
slides up on the web.
We may not have them
exactly before lecture,
because I'm often working
right to the bell,
but we'll have them
after the lecture.
So take down whatever
notes you want, but you
don't have to scramble
to get every word here.
By the way, the other
thing I should say
is that your contract
in this course
is not with whatever
materials on the web
or what you find from
past terms and so on.
It's really with us in
lecture and in recitation.
So we urge you to come to
lecture even though all of this
will be posted, because there's
other learning that happens,
and you have a chance to
bring up questions, and hear
other people's
questions, and so on.
I'm not going to
read through that.
But I want to have a little
picture that you can carry away
in your mind for what
we think of when we
think of a probabilistic model.
So we've got a universe
of possibilities.
We've got outcomes.
These are what are called
elementary outcomes.
Think of it as rolling
a die, for instance,
and I get one of six numbers.
So each of those is an outcome.
So here's the
elementary outcome.
I could number them
s1 to s n, and they
don't have to be finite.
It could be an
infinite number, a.
Continuum we'll see
examples of that later.
But if you're thinking of
a source emitting symbols
to construct a message, then
at every instant of time,
the source is picking
one of these symbols
with some probability.
So that's the kind of
model we're thinking of.
So here are the
elementary outcomes--
s1, s13, and so on.
You've got events,
and events are just
collections of outcomes.
So events are sets.
So this is the event or
set a, just a collection
of elementary outcomes.
I say that the
event has occurred
if the outcome of the experiment
is one of the dots in here.
If the dot is out
here, if this is
what you got when you
ran the experiment,
the event didn't occur.
So an event is just a set,
a subset of these outcomes.
We say "the event has
occurred" if the outcome that
actually occurs is sitting
inside, in that set.
And then we can talk about
intersections of events.
We say that if this
event a and this
is b, the event a
and b corresponds
to outcomes that
live in both sets.
So if I roll a die, and I get a
number that is even on a prime,
that tells me what
that number is.
So if this is the event
of getting an even number
on rolling a die,
and this is the event
of getting a prime
number on rolling a die,
what number do I get when
both events have occurred?
So I can identify
different events,
and then I assign
probabilities to them.
So I can talk about the
probability of an event.
And then you can combine
probabilities in useful ways.
So let's see, there's a lot
on here because I wanted,
in principle, to fit
it all on one slide
that you could carry
around with you.
Probabilities live
between 0 and 1.
The probability of
the universal set
is 1, meaning when you do the
experiment, something happens.
So it's guaranteed
that something happens
and therefore, u always happens.
So the probability of u is 1.
And then the probability
of a or b happening
is the probability of a
plus the probability of b
If a and b have no intersection,
if they're mutually exclusive.
So we say that two events are
mutually exclusive-- actually,
let me draw a c over here--
a and c in this
picture are mutually
exclusive because
there's no outcome that's
common to the two events.
So if one event occurs, you
know the other one didn't occur.
And so if I now ask what's
the probability of a or c
occurring, it's the probability
of a plus the probability of c.
You'll be doing this all
the time in this course.
You'll be adding probabilities,
but you've got to think--
am I looking at mutually
exclusive events?
If you've of got mutually
exclusive events,
then the probability of
one or the other happening
is the sum of the
individual probabilities.
If they're not
mutually exclusive,
then there's a little
correction you have to make.
The probability of
a or b happening
is the probability of
a plus the probability
of b minus the probability
of both happening.
All of this is quite intuitive.
Another notion that's
important is independence.
So we've seen that
mutual exclusivity allows
you to add probabilities.
Independence allows you
to multiply probabilities.
So we say that a set of events--
a, b, c, d, e, for instance--
are mutually independent if
the probability of a and b
and c and d happening is the
product of the individual ones.
But similarly for
any subcollection--
so you're going to call
a collection of events
independent if the joint
probability of their happening
in any combination
factors into the product
of the individual probabilities.
And again, this is
a computation you'll
be doing all the time
in different settings,
but you've got to think to
yourself-- am I applying it
to things that are independent?
Because if not, then
it's not clear you
can do this factorization.
We'll come later to talk about
conditional probabilities.
But the probability of a
given that b has occurred--
we can actually sort
of see it here--
the probability of a
given that b has occurred
is this area as a fraction
of the whole area there.
Sorry, the probability of
a given that b has occurred
is the probability of a and
b over the probability of b.
Given that b has
occurred, you know
that you're somewhere in here.
And what's the probability
that a has occurred given
that you're somewhere in here?
It's the probability associated
with that intersection.
One last thing-- expectation.
We talk about the expected
value of a random variable
as being basically
the average value
it takes over a typical
experiment, let's say.
And the way you compute
that is by computing
the average weighted by the
associated probabilities.
And we'll see an
example of that.
I didn't feel right just jumping
into Shannon's definition
of information without saying a
little bit about how you set up
a probabilistic model.
But with all that
said, here's what
Shannon had as the
core of his story,
and building on earlier
work by other people.
So if you're thinking of a
source that's putting out
symbols, the symbols
can be s1 up to s n,
the information in being told
that the symbol s i was emitted
is defined as log to the base
2 of 1 over the probability.
So what you're trying
to come up with
is actually a
measure of surprise.
Maybe "surprise" is a better
word than "information."
"Information" is
very loaded word.
But what you're
trying to measure here
is how probable is the
thing that I am just seeing.
If it's a highly
improbable event,
I gain a lot of information by
being told that it's occurred.
If it's a high
probability event,
I don't get much information by
being told that it's occurred.
So you want something that's
dependent reciprocally
on probability.
The log is useful
because that allows
you to have the information
given to you by two
independent events being the
sum of the information in each
of them.
And the calculation
is just this--
it says that if a and b
are independent events,
then the information I get on
being told that both of them
occur is 1 over log p a p b.
But that then just becomes the
sum of the individual ones.
So the advantage of having
a log in that definition
is that for independent
events where the--
I should have actually
perhaps written one more here.
Here's the information
in being told
that both events have occurred.
Because they're independent,
that joint probability
factors into the product of
the individual ones, which
then factors into the sum
of these two logarithms.
So here's the information
in being told a and b.
Here's the information
in being told
just a occurred, and here's
the information in being
told that just b occurred.
So the log allows
things to be additive
over independent events.
Now, the base 2 was
a matter of choice.
Hartley chose base 10,
Shannon chose base 2.
And he called it the "bit."
So when you measure information
according to this formula,
with the log taken
to the base, 2 you
call the resulting number the
number of "bits" of information
in that revelation.
I'm being told that
that's the output.
Now for this lecture and
probably only this lecture,
I'm going to try and maintain
a distinction between the bit
as a unit of information and our
everyday use of the word "bit"
to mean a binary digit.
It's unfortunate that they
both have the same name,
because they actually refer
to slightly different things.
A binary digit is
just a 0 or 1 sitting
in a register in
your electronics,
whereas this is a
unit of measurement.
And the two are not
necessarily the same thing.
So I'll try and catch myself
and say "binary digit"
when I mean something
that can be a 0 or 1,
and "bit" when I'm talking
about a measure of information.
But here, for instance, is a
case where the two coincide.
If I'm tossing a fair coin,
so it's a probability 1/2
that it comes up heads, 1/2
that it comes up tails, then
log to the base 2 of
1 over 1/2 gives me 1.
So there's one
bit of information
in being told what the outcome
is on the toss of a fair coin.
And that sort of aligns
with our notion of a binary
digit as being something
that can be either 0 or 1.
We don't usually
associated probabilities
when we use "binary digit,"
but with "bit," we do.
So Shannon has a
measure of information.
And there are examples we can
talk about there in the notes,
so I won't go through them.
And I think I've
said this already,
so I'll pass
through that and get
to his second important notion,
which is the notion of entropy.
The entropy is the expected
information from a source.
So what we have is expected
information from a source
or from the output
of an experiment,
but if you're thinking of
a source emitting symbols,
this source can emit symbols
s1 all the way up to s n,
let's say, with probabilities
p1 up to p n, let's say.
And the sum of those
is going to be 1.
If I tell you that s1 was
emitted by the source,
I've given you an
information log 2 1 over p1.
If I tell you s1
was emitted, that's
the information I've given you.
But if I ask you before
you see anything coming out
of the source, "What's
the expected information,
what information do
you expect to get when
I run the experiment,
when I produce a symbol,"
then you've got to
actually average
this quantity over all possible
symbols that you might get.
But it's got to be
weighted by the probability
with which you're going
to see that symbol.
So this is exactly
what I had defined
earlier as an expected value.
So the entropy of the source
is the expected information--
or let's say the expected
value of information
you get when you're told
the output of the source.
And so if the emission is s1,
then the information is this,
but that happens
with probability p1.
If the emission is s2, that
carries this information
that happens with this
probability, and so on.
So this is the entropy.
Shannon is borrowing
here from ideas
developed in thermodynamics
and statistical physics.
People like Gibbs
at Yale in 1900
already had notions
of this type.
His innovation is in
actually applying this
to communications, and he has
several constructs beyond this.
We'll come to some
of them later.
But up to this point,
he's making a connection
with what they do in
statistical physics,
except they're
usually not thinking
in terms of information.
They're thinking in terms
of uncertainty here.
And they're not thinking of
sources emitting symbols.
So this is the entropy.
So for instance, if
you've got a case where
you have capital N symbols and
they're all equally likely,
then the probability of any
one of them is 1 over N.
So what is the entropy?
Well, it's going to be
summation i equals 1 to N,
each probability is 1 over N.
I take log 2 1 over 1 over N.
So what does that end up being?
That ends up being--
I can take the log 2
N out, and then I've
got the summation, 1 over N.
And the result is log 2 N. So
if I've got equally
likely symbols, N of them,
then the entropy, the
expected information
from being revealed what
the outcome is, is log 2 N.
It turns out that this is the
best possible case in the sense
of maximum uncertainty.
If you're looking for a source
that's maximally uncertain,
that's going to surprise you
the most when it emits a symbol,
it's a source in which all
the probabilities of symbols
are equal.
Symbols are equally likely--
that's when you're going
to be surprised the most.
Now you can see this in a
particular example here.
Let's look at the case
of capital N equals 2.
So we're just talking
about a coin toss.
I toss a coin.
I get heads with
probability p, some p.
I get tails with some
probability 1 minus p.
Instead of saying
"heads" or "tails,"
I could make it look a
little more numerical.
I could say C equals 1 for a
head, C equals 0 for a tail.
That's sort of coding the
output of the coin toss.
And now I can evaluate the
entropy for any value p
you give me.
So if you've got a fair
coin with p of 0.5,
I evaluate the entropy.
And I find, indeed,
that it's one bit.
So the average
information conveyed to me
by telling me the output of
the toss of a fair coin is
one bit of information.
But if the coin
is heavily biased,
then the average information
or the expected information
can be a lot less.
This turns out to be a
very tight connection
to this idea of coding.
So let's actually take
an extreme example.
I've taken the case
now where you've
got a terribly biased coin.
It's not p equals 0.5,
it's p over 10 to the 24.
I picked 10 to the 24 because
log to the base 2 of that
is easy.
So it's a very small
probability of getting a head.
In fact, if you were to
run 1,024 trials, the law
of large numbers, which I
haven't put on that one sheet,
but you probably believe this--
if I had a coin that had a 1 in
1,024 probability of coming up
heads, and I threw
a coin 1,024 times,
I'm more likely to get a
heads once than anything else.
And actually in a
very long stretch,
that's just about exactly the
fraction of heads that you get.
That's the law of large numbers.
In that case, what
is the entropy?
So I've got p times log 2 1 over
p plus 1 minus p times log 2 1
minus p.
I'm just evaluating that
parabolic-looking function.
It's not quite a parabola.
And I see that I've got just
0.0112 bits of information
per trial.
So unlike the case
of a fair coin--
remember, in the case of
a fair coin it equals 0.5,
I have an entropy of one bit.
That's the average information
revealed by a single toss.
Now I'm down to much less.
I'm down to 0.0112
bits per trial.
And the reason is that this
coin is almost certainly
going to come up tails, because
the probability of heads
is so small.
So for almost
every trial, you'll
tell me, "Oh, it came up tails."
And there's no surprise in that.
There's no information.
There's just the occasional
heads in that pile.
And when you tell me that came
up heads, I'll be surprised.
I get a lot of information.
But not when I average it
out over all experiments.
It's actually low average
information there.
So if you wanted to tell me
the results of a series of coin
tosses with this coin,
you toss it 1,024 times,
and you want to tell me what
the result of that set of coin
tosses is, it would seem to
be very inefficient to give me
1,024 0's and 1's, saying,
it was 0, 0, 0, 0, all
the way along here.
Let me say it this way--
here's one way to code
it that would tell me
what you got in 1,024 trials.
You could say, well, it was
tails, tails, tails, tails,
tails, tails, tails, oops,
head, tails, tails, tails.
So you could give me that
1,024 binary digits with a 1
to tell me exactly
where you got the heads.
It seems a very inefficient
use of binary digits.
A binary digit can actually
reveal a bit of information,
and here you are using
1,024 binary digits
to reveal much less information.
In fact, let's see--
0.012 bits per toss
times 1,024 is really
all the information there is.
And you shouldn't be
using 1,024 binary digits
to convey that information.
If you're sending it
over a transmission line,
it's a very inefficient use.
So can you think of
a way to communicate
the outcome of this
result with something
that's much more efficient?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
GEORGE VERGHESE: Yeah,
just since you're
expecting in 1,024 tosses
that there'll typically
be just a single one,
just encode the position
where that one occurs.
How many binary digits
does it take to do that?
10, right?
1,024-- you've got to tell me,
is it in position 1, 2, 3, 4?
You've just got to be
able to count up to 1,024.
So if you send me
10 binary digits
to tell me where
that 1 is, you'll
have revealed what the outcome
of the sequence of experiments
is.
So 10 binary digits
over 1,024 trials,
so here's the average
usage of binary digits--
binary digits per trial
if I use your scheme.
And that's much more.
That's much closer to the
actual bits per outcome.
And somebody had a
question on that?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
Is it actually less
than [INAUDIBLE]??
GEORGE VERGHESE:
It better not be.
And part of it might be
that I've rounded this here.
Is it a small
rounding difference?
Did you actually
compute something there?
AUDIENCE: 0.0097.
GEORGE VERGHESE: Sorry.
AUDIENCE: 0.0097 [INAUDIBLE].
GEORGE VERGHESE: Oh,
is it not 0.0112?
OK, good, I'm glad
somebody computed that.
How did I get that?
Sorry.
AUDIENCE: This is also
only because a possibility
of 1 [INAUDIBLE].
GEORGE VERGHESE: Oh, I see.
What you're saying
is that this was--
right, you're saying
this is 0.99 something.
OK, I'm just saying that
we're in the ballpark
if we try to code
just for the single 1.
But there will be
cases in my experiments
where there might
be two of these,
and then I've got to use
a more elaborate coding.
I'll use a longer code word.
Those are less likely
events, so I've
got to factor in all
those probabilities.
Yeah, good.
I'm glad you caught that.
I don't want to get
too sunk in this
because I just want
to convey the idea.
The idea is that the
Shannon entropy actually
sets a lower limit to the
average length of a code word.
And so when you're trying
to do design of codes,
you're actually
trying to find codes
that will get you close to
the Shannon entropy limit.
So what I want to
just briefly mention,
and you'll follow
up in recitation,
is something called Huffman
coding, which you might
apply to a situation like this.
So you're coding,
let's say, grades
to send to the registrar.
A's occur with probability
1/3, B's with 1/2, and so on.
You want a coding whose
expected length will come
close to the Shannon entropy.
So the question is, what's
the Shannon entropy?
I hope I haven't jumped
over too many slides.
I have jumped over
too many slides.
Let's go back and find
the Shannon entropy here.
For that particular case,
if we compute the entropy,
we get 1.626 bits.
If you are communicating four
possible grades for 1,000
students to the registrar,
one way to do it
would be to use
two binary digits.
You can cover all four
grades, send 2,000 bits
to the registrar.
The entropy says that you've
got 1.626 bits per grade
on average.
So for 1,000 grades, you
should be able to get something
closer to 1626 bits.
So can you communicate a set
of 1,000 grades occurring
with these probabilities with
a code whose expected length is
closer to the 1626?
That's the task for designing
a variable length code.
Now, it turns out that this task
was set by Professor Fano, who
was a Professor here,
retired, but still
comes to our weekly
lunches, set as a term paper
in the course he taught on
information theory, actually
just three years after
Shannon's paper appeared.
He posed the
problem of designing
a variable-length code
whose expected length came
as close as possible
to the Shannon limit.
Huffman struggled with
that almost to the end.
Fano offered the option of
doing a final exam if you
didn't have a term paper.
He was about to give up
on it, and then came up
with an idea that
turns out to be
the optimal
variable-length coding
scheme for this scenario.
So what he does is, just to
very quickly finish with that,
he takes the two lowest
probability events,
groups them together to
make a single event that
is C or D with probability 1/6.
Then in that
resulting reduced set,
he looks at the two
lowest probability events,
combines to make
them a meta-event
with a probability that's the
sum of the individual ones,
and so on.
So he chases this procedure up--
take the two lowest probability
events, combine them
into a single one with
the probability that's
a sum of these individual ones,
in the resulting reduced set
look for the two lowest
probability events, and so on.
Build up a tree.
The resulting tree then
reveals the Huffman code.
The Hoffman code is guaranteed
to have an expected length that
satisfies this constraint, but
actually has an upper bound,
too.
It's within entropy plus
1 on the upper side.
We'll talk next time
about how to improve this,
but in recitation
tomorrow, you'll
get practice at a little
bit more leisurely pace
than I did here with
constructing Huffman codes.